I urge you captain to corn
surrender consider the men and women who
would lead into a lost cause
if the cause is just an honorable
they are prepared to give their lives
are you prepared to die today Tom one
cool customer yes sir Patrick Stewart as
Captain jean-luc Picard in Star Trek The
Next Generation the actor is returning
to the franchise to take on the iconic
role again after nearly two decades
Stewart first played Picard in 1987 and
continued for seven seasons and for
movies he's making his return in Star
Trek Picard the show airs on CBS all
access and follows Picard in the next
chapter of his life
strange I didn't know we were on course
to Mars
this isn't right
sir patrick stewart it delight that here
welcome thank you very much delighted to
be here you didn't want to do this role
again but as they say in Hollywood you
actually did take the meeting I took the
meeting because when I saw the names of
the people who were proposing this new
brand-new show with my characters the
leader as the main role I was
overwhelmed I I had never been
approached by such distinguished writers
before keeper gold fund Alex Kurtzman
and Michael Chabon yeah just like the
executive producer I think Kirsten buyer
I had to speak with them face to face if
only to say thank you so much I wish I
could have but I can't
you didn't want this to return to the
storyline from next generation you
wanted a clean and clear break and now
this show actually opens on planet earth
which is a little bit demure in a
vineyard right well it's Chateau pecan
truly is there free wine in this role no
we didn't run to that but I do have
several bottles stashed away what's the
appeal of a show about the far reaches
of the universe but it starts here on
earth it will be a little surprising for
a lot of fans and I have been saying -
I've been to conventions and Comic Con
and so forth be patient because the
world may begin very domestically in
central France but it won't be there for
long and things will happen they'll have
an extraordinary cast and I love sitting
here looking at all these faces yeah a
truly brilliant and very diverse cast
but you know it must feel really good
for you glad was just telling us in the
green room at Comic Con when you were
introduced he said it was like a freakin
airplane the applause for you was so
loud so and I think that's so lovely
that people are so glad you're back
what was your hesitation were you
worried that I don't want to do that
more I can't do it or so many times fast
no no none of that it was it was that I
felt we had told the sonnet yeah and and
I I felt that anything else that would
come in might undermine the good that
we've done because I'm very proud of
next generation yeah but it's not gonna
be that way it's it's looking very
excited what's it like for you to see
your old your old thing the one thing I
never want to hear are you prepared to
die today from your lips so it's your
voice boys Patrick is yes
it's the one thing you talk to these
guys you know I can wear caps and
sunglasses and all of them but the boys
I gotta keep yeah you were telling us
that you started acting when you were 12
mm-hmm and but and actually left school
at 15 but not even two days and two days
so what what what inspired you to act
what when I was 12
I met an English teacher sessile doorman
who is 96 he's still alive we talked on
the phone often and he first of all put
a copy of Shakespeare in my hand put
handed them around the class it was the
Merchant of Venice he said act 4 scene 1
which is the great trial scene Stuart
you're Picard's that you're Porsche
you're Bassanio and so he's the right
start reading and we all went yeah and
he said no not to yourselves out loud
this is a play it's drama it's not
literature it's drama that's the first
time anyone ever said that to me then he
put me in a play with adults because
there was a drama group in my school
which consisted mostly of teachers yes
so I I was acting with adults who were
also my teachers and I found the stage
was the safest place I had ever been
that will sound odd but why was it I
said well my home life was a little
chaotic yeah I felt so safe on that
stage and furthermore I wasn't Patrick
Stewart your teacher Muslim but very
very proud of you said that Star Trek
touches every corner of your life what
do you mean
well I when I said that I was referring
to actually doing it because I never had
this level of exposure in my life before
if you didn't go to the Royal
Shakespeare Company or maybe watch BBC
to listen to Radio 4 you would have no
idea who I was and and so and I was
unprepared for the the attention
exposure yeah much nicer word gene
roddenberry didn't want you in the point
did it no gene saw me the day after I
had been discovered by one of his
co-produces Robert justman at UCLA and
my meeting first meeting that morning
lasted about seven minutes and I was out
and he said no no what you were thinking
he's not the man and and then my name
kept coming up and there was a member of
Paramount somewhere that says I want to
hear no more mention of passage we're so
glad you're here I am all of my British
friends what do you think about Harry
and Megan have you been following this
following it I've been very much
involved in it actually because people
don't know what lies behind this thing
that has been happening and I happen to
the fact is we've made them an offer to
appear on Star Trek Picard and they they
have roles to play and very and making
mechanism actually and you're not
kidding Joe would be right back
you